hi I'm Eric Vossen whoo boy Marvel
finally released a trailer for Avengers
infinity war and sure maybe on the
surface it doesn't tell us more than
what we already knew
purple Bruce Willis is coming Avengers
will get rattled and the chrissa's will
out wise ass each other looking closely
at this frame by frame with our
obsessive paranoid eye you can actually
start to piece together how Thanos is
plot to gather the Infinity stones and
attack all the Marvel heroes might go
down so join me in my insanity and heads
up if any of my predictions in the beam
right possible spoiler warning okay
let's get started there was an idea to
bring together a group of remarkable
people
okay this trailer opens with narration
that should be familiar to you the voice
of Nick Fury is joined by Tony Stark and
later vision Thor and Black Widow to
echo Fury's line from the Avengers when
he aimed to bring the team's most
opposed rivals together at the darkest
hour the death well sort of death of
Agent Coulson
so repurposing the quote here makes a
promise of what this movie will be once
again the Avengers will assemble at a
dire moment but also in a way that might
close the door that Nick Fury opened all
those years ago that might be why Tony
Stark looks so grief-stricken here his
expression suggests that the Scarlet
Witch induced nightmare scenario from
age of Ultron of his fellow Avengers
slaughtered or maybe just passed out
after Avenger is coming true at first I
thought Stark was just holding his own
dirty hand here but it also kind of
looks like he's clutching a different
hand of a fallen friend whose hand is it
cap Scott Lang yeah it's probably kept
looking closely at the other visuals
here the planet here has an orangish red
turbulent surface with lightning storms
and that's not the earth I remember
that's because I don't think this is
earth check it out there are definitely
two stars in this solar system to me a
more likely scenario is that this is
Zander the home of the Nova Corps and
the guardians of the galaxy movies and R
is also part of H Ryanair a star system
remember the end of the first guardians
movies showed the Infinity stone in that
movie their purple hue Power Stone
contained in the orb was locked away
inside the Nova cores vault now later in
this trailer will see Thanos adding the
blues
basse stone to his gauntlet and the
power stone is already there so I'm
thinking baños his first stop is Xander
and he's gonna wreck this place back the
area in the shadow here could be the
ruins of that main urban center now for
comic readers this would make sense
because Xander has a long history of
getting their asses handed to him
actually now's a good time to explain
the comic origin of this movie Marvel is
adapting the Infinity Gauntlet comic
series along with the sequel miniseries
infinity war maybe also infinity crusade
it centers around Thanos a super
powerful being who is in love with the
physical embodiment of death known as
mistress death so he goes on an epic
killing spree leading him to assemble
these six infinity gems in his Infinity
Gauntlet basically becoming master of
the entire universe of course his plot
gets foiled and undone in ways that are
a little too complicated to get into
obviously the Marvel Cinematic Universe
has been setting up these events for
quite some time as far back as Stannis's
cameo in the post-credits scene of the
first Avengers when he grinned at the
prospect of courting death ya thought
you did there and already we're seeing
some possible versions of comic book
events Bruce Banner has crash-landed
into the sanctum sanctorum as Doctor
Strange and Wong looked down at him
concerned in the comics Silver Surfer
does this but Silver Surfer is currently
a Fox property like Fantastic Four the
x-men so unfortunately they won't be
part of this adaptation for now hurry
Disney Fox merger there's still time
let's move on to see if we could become
something more so when they needed us
we could fight the battles that they
never could in this section vision and
Scarlet Witch wanda maxima are
continuing their domestic romance that
we saw in civil war but this time vision
takes a more human form something
looking a bit more like paul bettany
amazing CGI their kid inside I'm sure
Bettany was thrilled to be able to do
one scene without the Crimson makeup and
the comics vision has gone under the
more human looking alter-ego of Victor
shade maybe he's doing that here or
maybe he's using his powers to take a
more easy on the eyes appearance like
mystique does or this could be a mental
projection of him created by Wanda
whatever this is notice how the mine
stone continues to glow on his forehead
and I like how in this look it appears
to smolder underneath the surface of the
skin like an ember it's depicts visions
infinity stone like a furnace that
powers him but also an an organic part
of him trying to burn its way out next
we see Thor his back turned to us
looking out a series of portholes now we
find at the end of this trailer that
these are the dirty unclaimed windows of
the Milano the ship of the guardians of
the galaxy looking closely outside those
windows appear to be the same oranjee
planet's surface that we saw in that
opening shot perhaps the Milano is
surveying the ruins of Xander and
realized in Thanos is in possession of
the power stone now and then we see what
looks like an emotional reunion between
Bruce Banner and Black Widow remember
age of Ultron left off with Hulk hanging
up on Natasha as he departed earth on
the Quinn jet a transmission that thor
ragnarok recently reminded us about who
by the way does anyone else think
Natasha is about to brush her hand
across that outreach palm at a
Hulkbuster armor there like she did with
Hulk and age of Ultron I still can't get
over that and yes that does look like
Starks Hulkbuster armor that we did see
an age of Ultron and the background of
this shot looks like the African nation
of Wakanda the home of Black Panther
some later shots in the trailer actually
give us more context about these details
so let's move on
you will know what it's like to lose to
feel so desperately that you're right
yet to fail all the same
okay so after the Avengers theme and the
Marvel fanfare this trailer jumps to new
york city feed stream starts avengers
tower visible and fog there I remember
Stark was decommissioning an Avengers
tower in spider-man homecoming moving
all operations upstate so that might
explain why Scott off guard in the city
now of course to regroup at strangest
sanctum on Bleecker Street in this shot
of Wong strange banner and Stark notice
how stark has a small glowing square on
his palm there at first I thought this
was just part of his tag like a hand
repulsor but looking closely that looks
a lot like that sold only in China vivo
phone that he had cap used in civil war
perhaps Stark has tried to connect with
cap on a private line to warn him about
the trouble coming his way in Wakanda
and it's we hear fan assists threatening
voiceover we get this shot of Peter
Parker's arm hair sticking straight up
this is almost certainly Peters spidey
sense you never got to see him making
use of his spidey sense in homecoming
but the director assured fans that this
version of spider-man does possess it I
love how infinity war conveys spidey
sense as a natural spur-of-the-moment
instinct for Peter it's a kind of
nervous reaction we would all have
except triggered by super sensory
perception instead of the American Girl
store and this is actually grounded in
real science spider-man's spidey sense
comes from a spiders actual ability to
sense vibration through tiny hairs that
cover their bodies way to make this a
teachable moment Russo brothers yes
science I also just love the visual of
Venice's mysterious giant ring hovering
over Manhattan with it hanging in the
fog like that it reminds me a lot of the
movie arrival with the massive shell
shaped structures that hovered around
the world
I think infinity war may be going for a
similar aesthetic and that sense of awe
and mystery at the opening act to the
movie evoke to get a closer look at this
thing in the next section
ready run so much
Dustin's still arrived
okay here a close-up of Thanos his
device shows us that it's way more
mechanical than I would have expected
compared to the shiny futuristic tech
that we've seen in the MCU with the
Asgardians or the sovereign or the
wakandans this looks much more retro
Star Wars it's almost like the gears of
a roller coaster like that bring a fire
carnival ride which according to urban
legends was probably even more deadly
than this thing is it also reminds me of
the rings of the wormhole device in the
movie contact which I've been weirdly
bringing up a lot lately it just makes
me feel like this device could open up a
cosmic portal for Thanos to arrive
through whatever it is it seems to be
associated with fire and floating debris
in the city below down on the street
level we get a better look at stark and
notice how he has a new arc reactor
embedded in his chest that's interesting
because remember stark had his chest
reactors surgically removed at the end
of Iron Man 3 and beam it at some seals
I'm wondering if this new arc reactor is
part of the bleeding edge armor from
these civil war comics fans been
bringing this up over and over again
hoping that we'll see in every new MCU
movie but it's based on tiny nanobots
that live in Starks blood and bleed out
of his skin assembling armor around him
wherever he is I don't know another big
chunky chest nuke doesn't really seem to
go with discrete bleeding that armor so
we'll see next we see someone stepping
over corpses now the editing here makes
it seem like this is Loki handing off
the tesseract to Thanos but if you look
closely these shots are actually all
from different angles so I'm gonna
sleuth out the truth here but real quick
big thanks to Merc Ari for sponsoring
this video
Macari is a free app you can actually
get it by clicking our download link in
the description below basically you
create an account and you can be a buyer
and/or a seller you can declutter your
life and put whatever stuff you have up
there you sell it and you just print out
a label and ship and make some sweet
sweet cash and yeah you can very easily
search for stuff to buy - all you have
to do is plug in any old search term
like say Avengers and BAM I just bought
a great vision Funko pop to remind me of
sweeter times when the mine stone was
still firmly in his forehead and it's
not just toys and collectibles you can
buy and sell anything at bargain rates
clothes cookware and in my case some rad
bb-8 swim trunks the real guys just
download shop and sell and put your
holiday shopping and more Kerry Sands it
just makes it so so easy
ok back to these Loki shots first these
shoes and
with a person stepping over the body
doesn't belong to Loki looking closely
that's actually a beanie ma a beanie ma
belongs to the Black Order the group of
henchmen who served Thanos the corpse
beneath looks similar to the garb worn
by the Asgardian refugees at the end of
thor ragnarok so I do think this scene
with Loki is part of that same scene
perhaps a continuation of the
post-credits scene after Ragnarok that
showed dannis is shipped the sanctuary -
dropping in on Thor and Loki ship
remember during that final battle of
Ragnarok it was implied that Loki
snatched the tesseract from Odin's vault
and I've dear eyes that Loki actually
set up this interception by Thanos his
forces to present the tesseract to him
fulfilling his promise from the Avengers
and endearing himself to Panos and
speaking of that mad Titan we get a good
look at his mug as he arrives through
this portal but I'm actually more
interested in where he is by the look of
the background behind him that
architecture looks very similar to what
Conda from the Black Panther footage
that lots of footage from this trailer
suggest we are in store for a major
battle sequence between the Avengers in
Thanos his army in Wakanda and to me
that is a pretty strong indicator that
Wakanda is the location of the final yet
to be revealed infinity stone of the
soul stone after it didn't show up in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 or Thor
Ragnarok many of us had theorized that
it could have been with Heimdall but if
that's still the case Ragnarok missed a
pretty big opportunity whip it out Black
Panther is the only remaining MCU movie
to come out between now and Finity war
and I'm betting we will see this
soulstone in Wakanda perhaps Cecil stone
is how to chala communes with the
Panther spirits which we saw a glimpse
of and a black panther trailer let's
move on
engage your defenses
and get this Manish shift
okay next up we get this big reveal of
Spider Man now deciding to wear the new
tech heavy armor that Stark offered him
at the end of homecoming I guess the
side of a big purple demigod dropping in
his friendly neighborhood was enough for
him to wet through his old one we still
don't know what all this suit is fully
capable of I love the eyes light up blue
many of us have previously speculated
that this could be based on the iron
spider armor that we saw in the Civil
War comics design-wise the iron spider
is kind of a fusion of Iron Man's and
Peter Parker's suits it has additional
appendages called Waldo's that make
spider-man look and function truly
arachnid it's very cool meanwhile Thor
appears in a different ring shaped
contraption holding parts of it together
with his body his move here could be a
call back to camp and Civil War when he
pulled that helicopter back on the roof
now if the ring we saw over Manhattan
was a portal I'm wondering if Thor's
ring here could be the other end of it
like maybe Thor is trying to block it
from opening further or letting anything
through then we get a few quick shots of
this mysterious figure tossing the spear
at another figure in shadow who catches
it now it's hard to tell but the first
one is Proxima midnight another black
order henchman and the second figure is
of course Captain America but he looks
different obviously there's the woodland
creature on his face but also he no
longer wears the classic Stars and
Stripes what's a deal that's because cap
is still on the run an enemy of the
country whose values he used to embody
the darker colors could be influenced by
the nomad version of cap in the comics
now the Winter Soldier and Civil War
storylines were influenced more so by
demand without a country Series in the
90s which seems to be continuing here
now to chawla has the best line of this
trailer ordering it gets the Spanish
shoot now he's calling back the end of
Civil War when caps shield was left
behind in Siberia after his brawl with
Iron Man and we'll see what new shield
cap gets later in Austrailia now before
I move on we get this shot of Iron Man's
Hulkbuster armor from this Wakanda
battle sequence I notice the way the
suit moves it leaps like a beast almost
unsure of how to control the repulsors
this isn't at all how stark looked when
he operated the whole buster in age of
Ultron he was totally in control as
usual I think this is Hulk or banner in
the suit are the reason I think this is
recently some descriptions of infinity
war lego sets popped up on a Russian
website describing quotes Bruce banners
Hulk Buster now obviously we can't trust
any sources from Russia these days and I
don't know why Hulk would need a Hulk
Buster if he can just Hulk himself but
if it is true that might be
we saw banner fiddling with that hole
buster arm earlier like perhaps in this
movie for some reason he struggles to
trigger his power that's what Bruce it
happens to a lot of guys let's move on
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers and
balancing universe
but this
does put a smile on my face
[Music]
okay some big action here including a
look at these nasty four-armed alien
these are out writers in the comics
they're genetically engineered parasite
assassins our writers are telepathic too
they can read the minds of victims by
sinking their hand into their temples
and they report their findings back to
the black order for Thanos now we'll see
how or if the telepathy comes into the
movie here they appear to be more
beastly infantry level foot soldiers and
as Thanos slams spider-man to the ground
he says Samus is something one considers
rebalancing interesting your choice
there balancing it's almost like Thanos
views his aggression the same way Darth
Vader's rise to power could have been
interpreted as bringing balance to the
force
like Vader thanasis is kind of a lawful
evil who seeks ultimate control in an
otherwise chaotic universe next is to me
the most heart-wrenching shot of the
trailer vision getting his mind stone
clawed out of his head or maybe it
doesn't look like they get it all the
way out I got the sceptre that's being
used now that's not Loki's sceptre which
was the source of visions mind stone to
begin with instead the sceptre belongs
to Corvus glaive another member of the
Black Order on west side of him is
Proxima midnight again leads to our
married next we see the shot of Thanos
with his gauntlet that I mentioned
earlier
adding the space stone along with the
Power Stone to at a six by the way the
other two that I haven't mentioned yet
in this video are the reality stone
which takes the form of the red ether
that we saw in Thor the dark world last
we saw that it was brought to the
collector for safekeeping
and of course the green time stone which
rests in the eye of agamotto around dr.
Strange's neck the rooster brothers have
described infinity war as in part a
heist movie with Thanos orchestrating
elaborate plots to steal each Infinity
stone there's also what looks like a new
design of the Iron Man suit which has
interesting ribbed streak design similar
to the streaks in black panther's
vibranium suit and even if stark fused
vibranium into that armor it doesn't
make any difference here Dianna's
delivers quite the right hook and if you
pause the frame you can see a chunk of
iron man's helmet flying off guys Dennis
just punched his frickin jaw out yeah
let's move on
[Music]
okay here we see more shots of this
wakanda battle and notice how flanking
T'Challa isma Baku aka man 8 who has
appeared in a black panther trailer as a
tribal leader who's a rival to T'Challa
srew and after this shot a falcon
lighting up the battlefield we get a
wonderful slow-motion master shot of our
heroes war machine winter soldier Black
Widow Captain America Hulk Black Panther
Falcon Okoye yay Black Panthers warrior
friend from the dorm Elisha a play by
tonight gorilla and Michonne from The
Walking Dead and I'm sure ant-man
somewhere in the frame and if you look
closely you can see that cap is wielding
a new type of shield wakandan vibranium
arm gauntlets vibranium is of course the
same metal that his classic shield was
made out of so it was generous of Shuri
I assume two challahs tech experts
sister to supply him with these she
sports her own similar gauntlets of
black panther let's move on to this
final section okay
Thor meets the guardians of the galaxy
here officially bringing these
delightful oddballs into the main MCU
narrative and the whole gang is there
including mantas from volume 2 star-lord
Peter quill with some goofy facial hair
and teenage grood now from the look of
this trailer this infinity war appears
to have divided the heroes across at
least three different fronts there's
Wakanda with team cap including cap
Bucky Falcon Black Panther Hulk Black
Widow and war machine then there's a New
York front with iron man strange Wong
spider-man and banner at least earlier
on perhaps also Scarlet Witch and vision
maybe we'll also get to see a man in
Hawkeye somewhere in there and then
there's a more cosmic front with Thor in
the guardians of the galaxy and then I
think we will see these three fronts
converge into a final battle with Thanos
that we've seen only short glimpses of
given the fiery orange color palette
other shots I'm wondering if it's the
Possible's and our planet from the
opening shot now it's here where it
seems very likely we will say goodbye to
some of our beloved heroes and that's
where I throw it over to you who do you
think is the most likely Avenger to die
after seeing this trailer and another
question I'm curious to hear your
thoughts about which avenger do you
think will be the most effective against
Thanos now I would say Doctor Strange or
vision since they're packing their own
Infinity stones whatever feelings
Scarlet Witch is gonna surprise us with
these strongest defense
tell me your thoughts in the comments
below or tweet me directly at ei boss
and
New York stars on Twitter at new rock
stars for updates on her videos like and
share this video and subscribe to new
rock stars for interesting detailed
coverage on everything you love
including everything marble Star Wars
and more and who really want to help
this channel you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our donors
especially Kelly hopper thanks for
watching bye